[Music]
hello Marta lights welcome to this
weekend Marvel I'm Ryan okay agent m and
I'm Jamie aka agent quantum and we are
so excited to have Michael Douglas here
with us for twin now I make a hank pym
look at all right we all got an a k
we're really excited now in Marvel
Studios Emma and the wasp obviously hank
pym has had such an important impact on
the Marvel Cinematic Universe did you
and Pete and talk about that no I came
in first of all Peyton is a total Marvel
comic freak they'd read our director he
knows them backwards and forwards and in
hindsight I realized I should say wait a
minute out you you're all up to speed
here I was not a big comic book kid
growing up so I need a little more help
so I got a little rough start right at
the first and then Pete looked at me
said oh oh right right right there are
people out there let me give you a
little help and then then he helped me
you know a little bit more but the fun
about this is this is what I think one
of the few Marvel characters where
you're seeing him an older age you know
all the other characters are sort of in
their prime
but because we're doing this thing where
it was so you're seeing you know Hank
Pym is sort of the senior get you know
guiding you know mentor which was which
was a lot of fun to actually play yeah
since I couldn't do all of the action
well you've played a lot of heavy
characters and heavy dramas throughout
your legendary career was it fun to do a
movie like Marvel Studios at men on the
wasp it was such a gas it was I can't
begin to tell you no you're right
it's a lot of time and you're when
you're dealing with you know
contemporary themes and and trying to
create reality and and Robert Oz just to
have this this magical world you know
I'm Robert Downey jr. and I did a movie
we loved called Wonder Boys which we
shot like in 2000 I got to know him
pretty well and he was a great help as I
talked to him early on about this whole
experience and and besides being a
wonderful actor he is a great sense of
of being a team player and really helped
to kind of give us the joy and the fun
of playing this Payton was a big help
and Paul Rudd is you know he's just
funny man
he's he's really funny I'm admire I mean
the toughest thing for me really was I
had to kind of carry the storyline you
know kind of keep the credibility of the
plotline Paul he got to go doing
interpretations you know one after the
other
oh sure you get to improvise I'm just
sitting here carrying the clock we used
to joke about that you also got to do
some green screen work right yeah it's
fantastic
no it's amazing I have all new respect
which is one of the reasons why I wanted
to do a Marvel film was I never done
green screen in my life and all of us
hadn't beaten this places and there's
nothing there and your directors is okay
or the meteor it's coming down here
right yeah yeah it's possibly passing by
you know or you sit there with with
there'll be 15 cameras on your work
because they're doing this stuff when
you're inside the suits outside the
rocket and they make you make spray sure
you do all the expressions all these
cameras click and everything else all
this stuff and then normally most movies
you go see a rough cut of the movie
there's no rough cuts because you want
to see what it's all done with all the
green screen which is the last thing
that's it's finished so you sit there
with the audience for the first time you
just like a kid you'll wow wow look at
this yeah it's awesome Michael thank you
for being here and of course get Marvel
Studios at men on the wasp on digital
blu-ray and 4k Ultra HD
[Music]